I heard that you did one of those DNA
tests that people are doing these days
to find out what their lineage is all
about that's the word on down that are
you what are you Irish you know what are
you guys said this before
Lisa Kudrow has a show called who do you
think you are and she asked me to
participate so they took some of my
saliva and she's I said you're not gonna
find me related to anything just Irish
trash and she said no no we're gonna
find out you're related Napoleon and all
that no no I'm not related to anybody
but she did say I'm the most Irish
person they'd ever found 99.8% Irish
which means I am more Irish than people
living in Ireland and dangerously inbred
so your body is he's constant he's
constantly breaking his ankles yeah snap
yeah I'm crazy
most most bodies are 70% water years at
70 percent Guinness what are you gonna
do that hurt my feelings so here's what
happened don't touch me I find this
place
I would always that's that no is you
yeah would you felt like the wood on the
desk no you got to use a little cream on
those hands and
I saw that touched your hand oh okay
sorry so um yeah it's called 23andme at
first I thought it was a dating site but
no it turns out to be one of those
ancestry places and people Swartz where
bite on the testimonials they give the
guy comes on he goes man I thought we
were like you know from Norway my family
all Norwegian you know every and but no
it turns out we are 100% black so I sent
away for the kit me and it's 90 dollars
and it comes with a little vial and you
put saliva into it yep and you seal it
you send it back they tell you you know
your whole lineage and all that I
thought this would be cool so I sent
away from I was so excited and it
finally came in the mail I went out to
my mailbox to get it on the way up to my
mailbox
I noticed that somebody had spit on my
car windshield I was livid you know how
I get oh yeah such a rage all I thought
who would spit on my car windshield and
then I remember for 90 bucks I could
find out it's worth it to me and I and I
would kill that person and all of his
ancestors yeah and so I scooped it up
put it in the thing sealed it up sent it
away I waited four weeks five weeks
finally I got the information on the
internet turns out it was bird crap but
this company is so good 23andme they
found out where the bird crap came from
a lot of a seagull seagull yeah from the
lower portion of the seagull
specifically the but well yeah we and it
was 80% crabmeat mm-hmm and 20% garbage
from a dumpster behind Santa Monica's
Ralph Wow
yeah this is very good you find out
everything you needed to know yeah yeah
so um so I'm eighty nine point one
percent Irish no and they come from
Ireland mm-hmm and there's a little town
called faecal true it's true it's
spelled differently but it smells the
same okay
not on that way continue have you here
you